[Music]
always here but rarely recognized look
in the mirror and see yourself for what
you truly are
[Music]
see you around ready
hey guys it's Charlie so today we're
going to talk about the Punisher TV
series they confirmed a whole bunch of
characters and it looks like they're
doing an arc from Punisher max which
ended like Big Punisher fans like please
do something really awesome
unless they're trying to deceive us
purposefully it looks like they've
confirmed who all the characters are
playing and it looks like you know
benbarnes who's going to be one of the
villains if not the villain will be
playing jigsaw so running down the list
there are mostly comic-book characters
that are one or two that don't appear in
the comics but most of these people pop
up during that first big punisher max
arc so that's the one you should read if
you want to read up on it so this actor
is playing micro he's listed as former
NSA analyst who assists castle which is
basically micro in the comics this is
going to be micros wife this guy is
going to be Curtis soil one of the guys
who fought with Frank in Vietnam in the
comics but remember on the TV show it's
said in modern-day so Frank is an
Afghanistan vet not a Vietnam vet like
he was in the comics so the interesting
thing about that though the fact that
they said it in modern day they had to
change some things it actually brings it
closer into continuity with that first
punisher max art because it deals with
Osama bin Laden stuff that's happening
in Afghanistan so it completely works
out usually when they bring stuff into
modern day they have to change a bunch
of other stuff but because of the bin
Laden arc the punisher max series takes
place in like the perfect timeline so it
completely works out they obviously
confirmed that Karen page is going to
pop up we even saw a couple pictures of
them interacting on the street they're
shooting The Punisher series right now
and they start shooting the defenders
really soon - I'll address that -
because if they're going to be shooting
both series at the same time it makes
sense that they would have him pop up at
least once during the defenders vs the
Punisher will crossover with the
defenders so next big punisher character
is Rollins this high-ranking CIA person
that Frank runs into because of all this
crazy stuff happening in Afghanistan so
he's also kind of a villain - but more
insidious than say like jigsaw jigsaw is
kind of like the walk-up and stabbed you
in the chest kind of villain the CIA
character more of like a stabbed you in
the back kind of person another
character not from the comics Sam Stein
is a homeland security agent who's
partnered with another homeland security
agent named ina who's also not from the
comics who will be tracking down Frank
so the way they've actually pitched the
series like the premise is actually kind
of weird because you think he's already
The Punisher because the daredevil
season 2 but the premise says Frank
Castle is haunted and hunted after the
murder of his family and becomes the
vigilante known in the criminal world as
The Punisher who aims to fight crime by
any means necessary so you're like wait
a minute didn't he already do that
during daredevil season 2 but really he
didn't pick up the mantle of the
Punisher til the very end of that so the
way I would think of it is is that
during the punisher season one more
people in that universe will be calling
him the punisher they'll be talking
about the punisher instead of a
mysterious gun man who's going after mob
targets but now it looks like they're
also going to be getting him involved in
a lot of CIA black ops via this punisher
max arc so if you want to know what to
read to get ready for punisher season 1
read that first punisher max arc but a
lot of you are asking now what does this
have to do with the defenders plot
daredevil Jessica Jones or Luke Cage
first season what was your favorite
favorite I like them all I like them all
there guy mean defenders yeah yeah so
you know Frank is largely a military
character so his story is gonna deal
with a lot of other things going on in
the military very bad things obviously
but remember Jessica Jones there was the
military group that experimented with
the pills there was a shadow corporation
behind that what they might do to tie
this all together because they announced
that Sigourney Weaver is going to be the
villain of the defenders she might be
behind that evil corporation that's
manufacturing those drugs in testing
people like the people that gave Jessica
Jones her powers that company like it's
all connected
through Big Pharma because Jeff Loeb was
teasing the iron fist series like we saw
the trailer but we don't know a whole
lot about what's going on in that series
yet they said that that's going to
examine take like a hard look at the top
1% of the 1% like the wealthiest of the
wealthy people people
Tony Stark money and he named dropped
Big Pharma as in like big pharmaceutical
corporations that are only interested in
profits don't care how they hurt people
so it all kind of trickles down to the
Punisher Jessica Jones Luke Cage
daredevil so that's probably what's
going to connect all of these TV shows
like the shadowy hand that's controlling
everything so that's like another thing
to the hand versus the chaste which is
much more mystical so you do kind of
wonder how that weaves in to the real
world stuff that's going on so that's a
completely separate thing I'm not
expecting too much hand stuff to be
happening during the Punisher which you
know makes you think of hand jobs
not too many hand jobs happening during
the Punisher but let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
during the Punisher series and do you
think that they'll drop Punisher before
defenders comes because they don't start
shooting defenders till the beginning of
November which is next week they've been
shooting The Punisher for about two to
three weeks now so what it looks like is
going to happen is is that they'll drop
Punisher and then like really quickly
after that drop defenders before the end
of next year because there is like a
contractual date that they have to hit
with defenders Punisher was like the
brand new thing that came after they
signed the big Marvel Netflix contract
when they signed that that was just for
the four heroes series and then the big
team-up and defenders Punisher was
nowhere in there he was kind of thrown
into the mix as like a bonus and then
everyone even the people at Netflix saw
how good he was and was like oh we have
to do a series for this too so they
threw him in there so now we have five
defenders technically although the
Punisher isn't so much a team based guy
so he'll probably help the defenders but
I don't expect him to actually be on the
defenders team formerly the working
title of that series too is called group
therapy as in like they all need group
therapy because they're so messed up in
the head so it's going to be awesome and
I will be doing more Punisher videos
obviously I should do a video for the
Punisher max series for the comic book
series so be sure to subscribe to get
that and I decided that just because it
seems like pino people aren't quite so
interested in agents of shield videos is
they are for other stuff that what I'm
going to do instead of an agents of
shield video tomorrow is do a fake
trailer for The Punisher goes
Crider team up show this should happen
even though they haven't confirmed
anything about ghostrider showing up in
the Netflix series I feel like we need
blade Ghost Rider in the Punisher to
have a crossover series so I'll make
like a fake trailer for Marvel's hearts
of darkness and tonight new episode of
the flash mirror master is debuting so
I'll post that after it airs big week of
comic book stuff doctor Strange's next
week too so if you live in an
international country you might be able
to go see it this week we don't get it
in the United States till the first week
of November so obviously that's when my
Doctor Strange video will post punisher
season 1 guest starring Lucille so while
you guys wait for that next video to
post you can click up top to learn like
a really true WTF behind the scenes DC
Comics story about Superman and Batman
and you can click down here to learn
what's going on with the Deadpool 2
movie and why everyone's freaking out so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
oh yeah